one of our principal rules in
storytelling is that story is King and
if something can go no matter how
precious it might be to you it must go
and in the process of telling a story of
this size over this amount of time we
ended up acquiring or accumulating a lot
of shots that uh that we really loved
and wanted to see in the movie but for
whatever reason we couldn't and since
all the shots that you're seeing here
represent the work of hundreds and
hundreds of very talented people uh we
thought it would be a shame if they just
ended up in a vault somewhere never to
be seen
again you're also hearing music here
that was written by Lauren Bal and was
part of a guidepost for us early on in
the process Lauren started writing music
long before we started shooting and over
the course of the the 3 years that it
took to make the film generated
somewhere in the area of 12 hours yeah
it it might have even been like 15 or 18
hours of music yeah a lot of music and
like these shots a lot of it involved a
fair amount of experimentation those
shots of Tom walking in the desert there
were things that we grabbed one morning
when it was too foggy for us to shoot
the scenes that we wanted to shoot and
because we had a bunch of crew standing
around we got the camera on the horse
and went to work other shots like this
where we were finding ways to introduce
the characters into the story when we
had a different structure to the First
Act of the
[Music]
movie